- On this episode, we
talk about Donald Trump,
user-generated content, and I answer two,
two Steve, two video questions.
(hip hop music)
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is the #AskGaryVee Show ♫
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 111, 1-1-1
of the #AskGaryVee Show!
I'm fired, guys.
I don't know if you know this,
but I'm in complete
belief that this show
is now completely ripping on fire.
The Instagram hustle that
I've been putting together,
DRock, do some editing,
is clearly working.
Enormous amounts of
new fans to the show.
I'm very excited
about the momentum.
The Facebook stuff,
the podcast push
has been intense, India,
over the last several days.
That's been fun.
If you're not subscribed to the podcast,
Android, iPhone, then
you're making a huge mistake
because you can listen
to the show on the run.
Also, before I get into the show,
there's something really
interesting happening
with the people that are
watching on Facebook.
A lot you haven't fanned
me up on Facebook,
so do that too.
A lot of right hooks on episode 111.
Really, interesting thing.
DRock show this screen.
Now I love this VaynerNation.
I love that people,
one of the things,
though, I've noticed that
has brought a lot of
awareness for this show
is the word of mouth which I
so appreciate from some of you,
but this little hack and
we saw it starting, kinda,
this is really just a social media tidbit.
This started happening on Instagram
'cause there wasn't an easy way
to communicate on
Instagram and share stuff
so people started tagging
each other in the comments
and we've seen a growth inside of Facebook
across up all of VaynerMedia
of people now seeing a post
and just tagging their friend
in the comments because the
alert system's so strong
and so I just wanna give a huge shout out
to everybody who is leaving a comment
with somebody's, you know, name in there
because they're passing on the show
and obviously that is social media.
Social media is the
plumbing of word of mouth
in our society.
That is the ultimate compliment
that I get from you watching the show
so I appreciate you so much.
And that's that.
And so, India,
let's get into,
- Uh huh.
- the show.
- Cool.
- [Voiceover] Avinash asks,
"What are your thoughts
"on using curated content?"
- Avinash, great question.
You know, it's funny, I'm not
a big user of curated content
at all.
And UGC, user-generated content,
is a thing that a lot of brands
at Vayner have played with.
You mentioned Guy.
Guy has done a ton of that.
You know, I think it's
a very smart tactic.
As a matter of fact, I think that
I've not done a good job in using it.
My biggest problem with
user-generated content
is the same reason that
I don't give quotes
to other authors even
though I get bombarded
every week of, "Can you give me a quote?"
If I'm gonna give you a
quote to your book, friend,
I need to read it.
I don't read books.
I don't have time to read those books
and the reason I have to read it
is if you see something
stupid in chapter 17
and there's so many people
saying so many stupid things
about business and marketing and social
that I'm scared to give my name on it
because then I'm endorsing you
but then you're saying like,
here's the way to hack
Twitter and it's wrong.
Or here's my point of view
on Pinterest or it's wrong
or here's how to manage
people and it's wrong.
I'm not on the same
side as a lot of people
on a lot of things.
It's just the way it is.
And that doesn't allow me to do that.
It's the same reason
user-generated content scares me
because I feel that if I'm
curating it, I'm endorsing it.
And who has time to go
down the rabbit hole?
It's why so many of you hit me up and say,
I wanna, you know,
I just got a spammy ass email
that I almost sent to you
and I was like, forget it.
It's just like, it was like so ridiculous.
It's like, Gary, can you
give me an hour of your time
to do this simulcast?
Which I didn't go down her rabbit hole
but I think she's charging for.
And like, she had this
whole thing and it said,
what's in it for you?
And it's like, you get side
by side of 19 other marketers
that she's also arbitraging.
The whole thing was so gangster.
I don't know, just a
lot of [bleep] going on.
Next question, India.
That had nothing to do with
the question at the end.
It was just me ranting of how pissed I am.
But my point was that she's
user-generating content.
Some of the names she had on there,
like I flat-out knew were
people that are like ugh,
lowest common denominator e-book stuff,
and just like I don't want to
be associated with that crap
and like, first of all,
she seemed like crap
but like, if she wasn't,
did she know they were crap?
Like, I don't know.
People are just not doing
their homework, India.
- [India] It's true.
- I never did my homework, in school.
But I definitely do it in business
and I know that was black and white
'cause that's how we roll.
All right, India, let's go.
- Uh, okay, from, sorry it said spammy ass
(laughter)
- Are you into spammy ass?
No, no, I mean, you
think it's a funny term?
- Yes, it's a funny term.
- I don't even know what
normal spammy ass is.
- [India] I thought it was funny.
- Got it.
None of the designers in here,
we clearly need a spammy ass,
Garbage Pail Kid-like,
that's what I need.
Get Zak to make me a spammy-ass
Garbage Pail-like t-shirt.
It'll be coming soon.
All right, let's get back into color.
We're black and white
almost the whole show.
- [Voiceover] James asks, "should
I be writing unique content
"on LinkedIn and Medium or
is it okay to repurpose
"the content I've already
published on my blog?"
- James, I'm a believer in both.
The truth is we've been
testing both as a team.
I do think, I think you can use,
specifically Medium and LinkedIn,
I feel very comfortable
in cross-pollinating
'cause I do think that
there's some intellectual,
above the brow, kind of,
similarities on Medium and LinkedIn
so those are very comfortable.
If you said, Medium and Snapchat,
the same one minute video,
I'd feel uncomfortable
'cause I think the context
of the room is different.
I think Medium and LinkedIn are similar.
So if you feel like your audience
and the context of the room,
the vibe when you go into it, are similar
then I think you can get away with it.
And so we look at Facebook and LinkedIn
and Medium having similarities
but you guys see what
I'm doing on Snapchat
if you're not following me,
put up the QR code, DRock.
Lot of editing here today.
Gonna be here late on a Friday,
no bullshit half-day
Fridays for you, DRock.
Anyway, you know, I'm not
gonna do the same stuff
on Snapchat that I'm doing,
and I'm trying to do different stuff.
But Medium and LinkedIn,
I feel fine with that.
Now, I think we're doing it
'cause we're busy as crap
and we're pumping out a ton of content.
You're different than me.
The people that are watching
are different than me.
If you have the time,
I think it's amazing if you could start
the for article with two
or three different lines
in the first sentence
that maybe even acknowledge of like
I'd love to do and India,
this maybe something
we should be doing.
I'd love to start doing more stuff
that's kind of like,
that start, that 99% of
the article's the same
but maybe the first two
sentences are something similar
like, you know I've been seeing
a lot of people on LinkedIn
and do blank.
Like all of a sudden you
make it very contextual
if you're doing it in LinkedIn.
Or, a common trend that we're
seeing on Medium is blank.
There's some interesting contextual things
you can do upfront that
an extra sentence or two
change makes it even more native.
So it's something to consider.
Cool.
- [India] Cool.
So this is from--
- India, you have rad,
hold on, get in here,
cherry...
- Oh yeah.
- Look at these cherry, you know what,
I know you're in black
and white now, DRock,
go color for a second so
we can get, hold on India,
(laughter)
- Ow, Gary.
- Don't worry, just stay tough.
All right, good.
That hurt?
- That hurt, yeah.
- Well, sorry.
Suck it up.
I mean, this is show biz, baby.
(laughter)
- Yo bro, it's your
opportunity to ask a question
on the #AskGaryVee Show.
- This is amazing.
- Gary who?
- Follow him, mother [bleep]!
Hey Gary, it's Matthias
Schaudig aka @mschaudig
here from Germany.
Just got a quick question.
I just thought up my new
YouTube channel and blog
and I'm putting out content
in German and English.
How would you manage multilingual
content in social media?
Thanks for your answer.
- Do it again, the wink is amazing.
Do it again 'cause I really enjoyed it.
- To begin the whole--
- Yeah, the beginning I didn't fully get.
- [Matthias] Yo bro, it's your
opportunity to ask a question
on the #AskGaryVee Show.
- Gary who?
- [Matthias] Follow him, mother [bleep]!
(laughter)
- Amazing.
Matthias had an amazing, amazing video.
Big ups to you, I'm glad to
give you some exposure in here.
Make sure you leave a
comment in Facebook as well
to like get more fans out of this
'cause clearly you've
got a nice buzz going.
Not buzz like alcoholic, I mean, like,
not buzz like I drink wine all the time
when you're not looking!
(laughter)
I mean, I mean, buzz like
you got some good energy.
Look, I think, I think
you know to handle this
better than I do.
There's certain questions
that come along the show
that the truth is, I'm
not a practitioner in,
I haven't managed, I
mean our brands have and
I would say the one thing
that I would think a lot about
is if you're handling
them in two languages,
really use the capabilities
of Facebook specifically
that allow you to only
target people that are,
you know, German speaking with the content
and then only English speaking.
Huge opportunity there.
Obviously English is a universal language
at a lot of places at this point
so there's something to
think about there but
I think it's the targeting capabilities
and with Instagram getting
Facebook's targeting capabilities
late this year, I think
you'll have a chance where
you're able to segment properly
and plan where your content's going
by language and region.
And I think that's super important and so
I would say that it's the
organized planning upfront
of the distribution of the content
that you have more flexibility
around in today's world
that you should take full advantage of.
There's a lot of platforms that you can't,
Pinterest, Twitter, things of that nature
and there I think you're
just doing your thing.
I've seen a ton of people manage both.
I'm a big fan of something
with brands here talk
called Spanglish, you know,
which is like Spanish English.
I'm very intrigued by some
of the work we've done
for Latino brands where we
start a sentence in a Tweet
in Spanish and then finish it in English.
Have you tried the
German English play yet?
Where you actually are putting out content
that has both languages in it.
In the post and the copy
hack a little bit there.
I think I just gave a lot of people
a good little nugget there.
I think that will work.
I think you'll see a real
over-indexing opportunity there,
especially with the youth who
are playing in both languages
and who grew up in
households where, like I did,
with Russian and English.
You start a sentence in Russian
and you finish it in English.
That's how a bilingual works
and I think you should play with that.
Are you guys chatting with
each other during the show?
- [India] No, Nicky asked me--
- You're both smiling at the same time.
- [India] Nicky asked me if I was okay
'cause she saw me talking...
- Nicky Richard?
Yeah, she's fine!
All right, Nicky.
- [India] So Ricky--
- Ricky?
- [India] Yeah, wanted
your two cents about...
(laughter)
Are you laughing 'cause
I always use Ricky?
- [DRock] Oh, you always use Ricky.
- I'm like, Ricky says, well here he is!
We've been waiting for Ricky for years.
- [Voiceover] Ricky asks,
"What are your two cents about
"the Donald running for president?"
- Oh, India, you know I don't like
getting political questions.
You snuck that in.
I got caught for not
previewing them ahead of time.
What do I think?
I think this is America
and everybody who wants
to run, should run.
I'm very intrigued by the
story that's come out about
him hiring actors to be at his pep rally.
I thought that was funny
mainly because I was blown away
that somebody would actually
do it for 50 dollars
for the whole thing all day.
- [Steve] You do know what it's like
being an actor in the city?
- Clearly, I don't.
Because I think you can go to Goodwill
for two hours, buy stuff,
and sell it on Ebay
and make more than 50 bucks.
Take that, all you actors.
There's a hack for you.
I think that,
I think he says a lot of outlandish stuff.
I think that America is
more divided than ever
on the left and right
because people are self-selecting
what they wanna listen to now
because you do have Fox and CNN.
You have the internet where you can go to
very left and right places
and I think it's an intriguing
thing that's happening
in general in social media right now
which is I'm very concerned
that people are not getting
rounded scenarios to the world
because it's so easy for you to just go
directly into what you believe
and you're having a very
intriguing thing happen
in college where people are
seeing who their roommates are
on Facebook before they go now,
figuring out who they are,
and then, kind of, asking out
and pairing up with, like,
I'm a hipster and I wanna
room with a hipster.
I've always been very proud of myself
in doing controversial things
like, for example, in
the height of post-9/11,
going online, scared that I was going
to Al Jazeera's website
to watch the stream
because I was, like, am I being,
'cause I already knew I was being watched
before everybody knew
they were being watched.
And I go I hope they're not mad at this
because I really do, you know,
don't forget I'm a
child of a Soviet family
whose mother wrote a book report
that Fidel Castro was the
bravest man in the world
and believed it in her heart and soul
that this little country
right next to this bad empire America
and then I grew up in
America and so, like,
there's always different perspectives.
I think Donald will absolutely resonate
with a small segment of
people on the right side.
I'd be flabbergasted if
he won the nomination,
but I think, my intuition net net
is Donald has the capability of surfacing
a conversation during this process
that could be healthy.
And I do believe that anybody
to the extremes of anything
have that potential and I'm hoping
that weirdly that gets people,
reminds people we're more aligned
than we're different and
right now it's really intense
in US politics in my opinion
on how separated we are
and so my hope, as an optimist,
'cause that's who I am.
He brings a singular issue
during his short run,
'cause I don't see him
winning the nomination,
though he could, that
may actually bring value
to the conversation.
I'm intrigued by that potential
probably more than anything.
That was a pretty,
that was a way better answer
than I thought was coming.
(laughter)
Snuck some things in, Sid you liked that?
We haven't shown Sid the intern yet.
Just show him.
(laughter)
Showed you.
- [DRock] You didn't say Ricky.
- In the episode?
Right, I always use Ricky
but when I was actually answering Ricky,
I barely said Ricky.
Ricky.
- Ted Rubin here @TedRubin on Twitter
and Gary, the question I have for you
is about all this talk you've had about
self-awareness lately
and I love the idea of
understanding what our talents are
and what they're not but my fear
is that we're gonna get into a mindset
of things we can and can't do.
Robert Browning says, "A man's reach
should exceed his grasp."
I want people think that they can try
and do a lot of different things
and I'm afraid it'll bleed to our children
and make them start saying
what they're good at
and what they're not good at.
Let me know how you feel about that
and how you can incorporate that
into your self-awareness talk.
- Ted, big ups to you.
First and foremost, you've
been, you know, again,
back to the theme of the show
not digging fully deep,
I'm not completely sure
but it's been really fun
to watch from afar of
you amassing an audience
and people really respect
you and kudos, do your thing.
I think this is a great
question and a challenging one.
First and foremost, here's
the way I answer it.
This.
Nothing completely one way
or the other is ever healthy.
You should always be
pulling from directions,
finding a blend.
I will say that I think people
are way more, at this point,
June 2015, in belief that
they can do anything,
are good at everything,
should try everything,
should work on their weaknesses
so I believe that I'm being aggressive
in starting a conversation
that lends itself
to like drawing a line of
strengths and weaknesses
that I think is very small.
I do not believe this
is a big conversation.
I believe modern parenting is like,
hey little Steve, you
can do anything you want.
Steve sucks at basketball.
(laughter)
He can't do everything he wants
and the amount of people
that want to play basketball
for a living or sing or
wanna be an engineer.
You know, like a, entrepreneur,
I mean you know how I feel about that.
So, I think that, Ted,
I think you're right.
I think right at this moment,
my point of view on this is so small
compared to the overall conversatIon
that I'm going 100% all in
and I don't want to hedge
against it with your point
which is correct
because I think the whole
market's hedging against it
and thus, I'm just trying to crackle it.
It's the same way I talk
about social media marketing
versus traditional TV.
I believe in TV but I don't
need to advocate for TV.
99% of the market's advocating for TV.
I believe that the
market, 90% of the market
is advocating for you
can do whatever you want,
you should try to do everything,
you should push yourself.
They package it in you
should try new things
and push yourself.
I don't think people
are talking enough about
be very self-aware, know
what you're good at,
force yourself, guys,
I don't know if you've broken this down.
Do you know what forcing yourself
to be self-aware, do you know
what that process entails?
Drinking a shit-load of humble kool-aid.
Uh-huh, like it's insane
of how much, like,
it's why I talk about liking to lose.
Like, it's insane of how much humility
I've had to instill to now
make it optically look like
I have too much ego and self-esteem.
So many of you, the first
time you consumed me,
some of you, like I'm really
getting in my Facebook mentions
as a lot of you have noticed.
Plenty of people sharing my stuff
and their friends are
saying screw this guy,
ego for days, full of himself.
I get it but what it actually is
is the post game of me being really humble
every minute of my life to recognize
what I should stay away from.
And I think people have
not gotten into that gear
so Ted I would say that I
get it and I agree with you.
And everything should
have a push and a pull.
I just think the market is way, way
in the direction of (pats Steve's back)
and I think that we need a
hell of a more a lot of like
you kinda suck at that, you
may want to focus on that.
Now, if you love that, then do it.
But you need to know what
that comes along with
which is if you love singing
more than breathing, cool
but you're gonna wait tables
and you're gonna make eight bucks
and that's great!
Because guess what?
I pay the price for doing what I love
in a lot of different ways.
And so that's just life.
That's just life.
Cool.
- [Man] I wish I had the little
dance floor over on Steve.
(laughter)
- Question of the day,
what are you doing this weekend?
I'm asking this specifically 'cause I know
this is gonna air later on Friday night
and I'm curious to see,
get everybody in there,
get everybody in there
to try to quickly answer.
I appreciate you guys.
I'm really enjoying the show.
I'm really, really enjoying the show.
This has really, really been enjoyable.
Your engagement, your
comments are really feeding me
and as it's happening
more, I'm feeling more hype
and so I appreciate you.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Ready?
Psst, psst.
Yeah, your speakers are fine.
It's me, Gary.
Here's the podcast bonus question.
(hip hop music)